lawrence today
he here's his quote let's take a look at
what he said and then let's analyze what
it may mean i'm intrigued by this oh we
don't have the quote the bottom line is
this and i'm going to paraphrase to the
best of my limited recollection
he's not sure what he's going to do
and
that to me
is an indication that he understands
that
he's going to end up with a really bad
team
if he comes out this year now here's the
reality
you're always going to end up with a
really bad team borrowing a trade
barring an acquisition of a pick by a
better team so whenever you come out
that's
what you're looking at
i think his better move shireen
is to just make an eli manning john
elway power play and i'm surprised guys
don't do that more often i don't know
who advises them on this but i think
there's a way to make the argument
without being perceived as a jerk and
and let me tell you this any player out
there now or in the future if you ever
do this i will support you a hundred
percent
the argument is
the draft isn't fair i got to pick my
college i should get to pick my next
destination and we have seen time and
again quarterbacks who go to a bad team
with a bad coach and a bad owner and a
bad everything and they're ruined
and they never get a second chance
i don't want to be that guy
i want to pick where i go
so
i don't want to go to the team that
holds the first overall pick and i'm
making sure that everyone knows that
right now and you know what if that team
picks me i won't sign a contract i'll
sit out the whole year and i'll re-enter
the draft next year if he has misgivings
and reservations about what to do that's
what he should do because there's no
reason playing football again next year
there's no reason to play for free next
year if you want to avoid the jets or
whoever else has the first overall pick
and you don't want to go to a bad
dysfunctional team your leverage is to
say don't draft me because if you do i
will never sign with you that's what he
should do
two ways to do it mike and the mannings
did it both ways peyton manning was
coming out in 1997 jets had the first
pick and and peyton said i'm going back
to school and ended up being picked by
the colts then the next year and then
you go to eli manning and obviously they
had the power play the chargers picked
him number one overall anyway he says
i'm not playing with you we all remember
the face he made on stage holding up
that chargers jersey uh and ended up
being traded to the giants where where
he wanted to go so absolutely he has
leverage trevor lawrence does and and he
needs to use that in whatever way he
wants to use it if he doesn't want to go
to jets he needs to make that clear that
he doesn't want to go the jets if they
end up with the number one pick and
figure out who he would like to go to
and and try to facilitate a trade to
where he wants to go just like eli did
but i think these players whole and i
think they figured that out i mean we've
seen this right through the social
industries things that have happened
they hold way more power than they think
they do and i think they've started to
figure that out
you know the rest of the story on eli
manning i've heard over the years
is that
first of all
it was archie who took the public
criticism it's nice to have
a former football player as a father who
can be the one to say
i don't think my son should play for the
chargers but the reality is he visited
the chargers and he got mixed signals as
to whether or not the team really wanted
him marty schottenheimer was the coach
aj smith was the gm they hated each
other smith wanted eli and marty didn't
that was the impression eli got so he
doesn't want to go to a place where
it he's not sure whether or not they won
and that was part of it and it worked
out and and for trevor lawrence it's
very simple if you're thinking about not
getting paid to play football in 2021
then then make it known publicly or
privately you're not going to go to this
team this team this team this team this
team and if any of those teams draft you
you're not signing a contract with that
team unless that team is going to be
trading him to a team that he will play
for and if it does and if and if they
don't like it he'll sit out the whole
year and it'll enter the draft again in
2021 which is what i'm waiting for
someone to do
we've said ever since his freshman year
right mike that he would be the number
one overall pick
who would you have taken last year if
you're the bengals would you have taken
joe burra or would you have taken trevor
lawrence it would have been an
interesting decision
yeah it would have been and i probably
would have taken trevor lawrence just
because joe burrow had that one great
year now so far
burrow has played extremely well but he
had that one great year at lsu and
before that he wasn't even on the radar
screen for a first round pick so uh i
probably lawrence though because he's
got he's got the body of work he's got
he's done it more
more
uh
on a on a longer basis i don't know why
i'm struggling with such simple words
and it's only tuesday he's done it
longer than joe burrow so that's what
i'm trying to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports